[Music]
straight ahead all on crime daily
the sandy hook defamation trial it just
is the fakest thing since the three
dollar bill jurors are shown videos of
alex jones mocking the parents of
victims and the doomsday cult duo this
case is tough enough without the
sensationalization
that is the potential of the media
attorneys argue over the presence of the
media in future court proceedings could
cameras be banned plus after being
acquitted in her teen daughter's murder
rebecca rude is sentenced for the one
charge she was convicted of and later
can you tell us
what condition you found tim in
yeah blood over his eyes jurors hear
from family members of the victims in
the pike county massacre trial of george
wagner iv law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer the
prosecution grills and alex jones
representative who admits an article
posted to the infowars website had
inaccurate information about the sandy
hook shooting this comes as part of alex
jones's defamation trial out of
connecticut where 15 plaintiffs filed
lawsuits against him after he claimed
that the school shooting was a hoax put
on by crisis actors to push gun control
the plaintiffs made up of the family
members of eight of the students killed
and an fbi agent say jones's followers
have harassed him and even made death
threats jones has already been found
liable for damages in this case meaning
jurors will now decide how much jones
should pay he was already ordered to pay
49.3 million dollars in a separate
defamation case out of texas on thursday
jurors were shown multiple videos of
jones's infowars program in which he
mocked the parents of sandy hook victims
later a free speech systems
representative admitted an infowars
article published inaccurate information
you got parents laughing
watch this
method acting
i mean it's just ridiculous
you got coroners that start laughing and
i don't mean uncomfortably i mean like
laughing with the state police when
they're giving press conferences i mean
it just is the fakest thing since the
three dollar bill
this article
reporting that the fbi said no one had
been killed at sandy hook according to
its statistics was false yes
correct it's not right that's right
not right mean not true right right fbi
never said that
but what don salazar was saying to his
audience was that there were these
statistics
that the fbi put out and that according
to don salazar those statistics said
that nobody had been killed
correct
that's what the article says yes and in
fact
the statistic and the fbi does report
crime statistics every year correct yes
and in fact the fbi statistics that adan
salazar was referencing
did report
the murders at sandy hook correct
i believe they did
joining us today is former swat and
chicago area detective lisa lockwood and
co-host terry austin lisa there have
been fireworks in this case since
openings has there been one that you
think hey this is going to bury jones
when i when i say this now saying one
thing particular it's a compilation of
the same thing and that's just
re-traumatizing the family doxing family
members posting photographs of a child
who was deceased and killed that day and
saying it was an actor having his team
on the ground
live streaming and harassing victims
online so i would have to say
re-traumatizing these victims over and
over again was is probably is what is
going to seal it for him especially the
manner in which he did as you described
the recording and sending people on the
ground terry between their witnesses and
how they are running this case do you
see a strategy being used here uh by
jones's attorneys or is this just chaos
well you know what actually brian it is
chaos but i do see a twofold strategy
first of all i think that norm mattis is
throwing out multiple theories he's
literally trying to confuse that jury so
for instance he said that the families
are exaggerating the harm because
they're doing it for political reasons
so i definitely think he is trying to
put other thoughts in the minds of that
jury but secondly i think that they are
trying to make a record for an appeal so
for instance the judge as we all know
already has a default judgment on the
record and this is the penalty phase but
on tuesday that judge basically said
because they failed to turn over
analytical data for that website that
now they cannot introduce evidence
regarding the fact that they didn't
profit from the sandy hook remarks
that's going to kill them these are our
sanctions i think they are deserved but
they could be grounds for appeal so it's
kind of chaotically organized that's
what i used to tell my mom my room was
like when i was a kid so they've got
some kind of organization makes sense
well switching now to california where
federal prosecutors now recommend an
eighth month prison sentence for the
woman who admittedly staged her own
abduction in 2016. back in april sherry
poppini pled guilty to two counts of
mail fraud and lying to an officer the
charges stem from a november 2016
incident when papini allegedly went
missing 22 days later she was found on
an interstate about 150 miles south of
where she was reported missing papini
claimed two hispanic women in a dark suv
abducted and tortured her but her
ex-boyfriend told investigators papini
actually stayed with him during the time
she was missing and that she inflicted
injuries including branding to herself
papini was married with two children at
the time according to court documents
papini will pay more than 300 thousand
dollars in restitution to the agencies
involved in the search for her still
ahead of law and crime daily a sentence
is handed down from the woman convicted
of abandoning her daughter's corpse
but first the doomsday cult duo laurie
valodebo fights to ban the media from
the courtroom of her coming trial
[Music]
welcome back half of the so-called
doomsday cold duo appears back in court
over emotions attempting to ban cameras
from future proceedings chad dabo and
his wife lori valodebel faced charges in
the deaths of lori's two children j.j
valo and tyler ryan as well as dave
bell's first wife tammy the pair were
dubbed the doomsday duo for their shared
belief in the end of days the couple was
married in 2019 just weeks after dave
bell's first wife mysteriously died in
her sleep and valodebel's youngest
children went missing in june of 2020
the remains of jj and tyler were
recovered on chad dabell's property at
an appearance on thursday attorneys for
both sides argued a motion to ban
cameras from future hearings and the
coming trial in january attorneys for
valor day bells said in previous
hearings camera operators zoomed in on
their client an unnecessary amount
what's the point to mock her
to make fun of her
to humiliate her
does it have any value to the public
other than the prejudiced
potential church against her
no
no value at
all so does it help the court find a
fair and partial jury and voicing when
they zoom in on my clients every facial
expression
no it doesn't the media has a right to
be there they don't have a right to
broadcast it or have cameras and the
state believes that the stark difference
between watching a live or video
of a proceeding as opposed to reading a
report on in a
newspaper judge stephen boyce also heard
from an attorney representing 33 media
agencies from across the country that
oppose the ban judge boyce did not make
a ruling on the motion but will later
issue a written decision
terry the prosecution and defense agreed
that cameras should be banned from the
courtroom we want to see the trial live
stream and of course we're a long crime
daily but
was what was uh what she was arguing was
that persuasive
you know i definitely don't think that
the argument to ban the cameras are
persuasive at all i think they should
fail so
they're trying to say that the media
abused this privilege and they took
photographs and videos that were up and
close to laurie vallo and that
technically the conversations might be
heard between laurie and her attorneys
and written notes might be photographed
and basically i think those arguments
should fail and i definitely don't agree
with what the prosecution is saying
they're saying that it's the same as
reading it later no it's not i think
that it is definitely in the public's
favor to see what's going on this is a
case that's already been sensationalized
it's something that i think the public
wants to make sure justice is served and
everyone knows about it and everyone
wants to see exactly what happened i
mean speaking of everyone knowing about
it lisa netflix recently came out with a
documentary sins of our mother
documenting lori vallo's life now
documentaries have exonerated and
convicted criminal defendants what do
you think this series will do here
yeah you're exactly right and i actually
watched it last night and it is um so
powerful in regards to
laurie valo's son lori bellows mother
all of them implicating lori in doing
all of this so i think because this
trial's in 2023 probably during the
vorder process
they will ask people if they had saw
seen uh the documentary and then try to
eliminate those people but
i'm
the high profile case of robert durst
all good things in the jinx those two
movies we know the outcome of that and
he was found guilty
all right thank you for not spoiling the
documentary on netflix so people could
still go and check it out but of course
come back to law and crime to check out
idaho versus chad and lori valodebel
in a maryland of victory for the man at
the center of the famed serial podcast
as prosecutors file a motion to vacate
anon syed's conviction and call for a
new trial syed's case rose to fame in
2014 when the podcast serial broke
listening records the investigative
series cast doubt on syed's 2000
conviction for the murder of his high
school girlfriend 18 year old heyming
lee since his arrest syed has maintained
his innocence he has been behind bars
since 1999 arrests in the motion if the
motion is granted prosecutors say they
will request that syed be released on
his own recognizance or have bail set
syed would also be put into a new trial
status and his convictions would be
vacated the state could then dismiss the
charges or bring a new case against syed
depending on what an investigation finds
back in march law on crime daily
reported that dna testing was ordered on
the victim's clothing as part of the
state's attorney's investigation the
results of the test are still pending
coming up on law and crime daily two
witnesses allow audio and video
recordings of their testimony as george
wagner iv stands trial for murder plus
after being acquitted for her daughter's
murder a missouri woman is sentenced for
the abandonment of her corpse
[Music]
welcome back a missouri woman acquitted
of murdering her 16-year-old daughter
stands before a judge to learn her
sentence for the sole charge she is
convicted of rebecca rude was initially
charged with killing her daughter
savannah leckie who had autism and
burning her body in her yard this after
roone gave up her daughter for adoption
when she was a baby but the two came
back together later when leckie
exhibited some behavioral problems as a
teenager while in the care of her
adoptive parents roo's defense argued
her daughter committed suicide and that
she panicked when she found her daughter
dead following just a few days of
testimony the case was handed over to
the judge to decide the verdict since
rude opted for a bench trial without a
jury weeks later the judge handed down a
not guilty verdict for all but one count
abandonment of a corpse a felony
punishable by up to four years behind
bars on thursday rude was sentenced to
four years in prison but she was given
credit for her nearly 1800 days already
served she was also ordered to pay a 5
000 fine rood was transferred back to
jail where she will be released shortly
root's co-defendant and husband robert
pete jr also appeared in court thursday
for his involvement in the 16 year old's
death but the judge dropped all charges
against him pete was also arrested and
charged with first degree murder child
abuse felony murder tampering with
evidence and abandonment of a corpse
she's been out on bond for the last four
years and testified against rude at her
trial his case was delayed until
november for the court to find a
replacement for judge calvin holden who
had presided over rude's trial and
retired at the end of it
terry i know it's a lot of math a four
year sentence 100 800
days but do you think the punishment fit
the crime for rood considering this
split decision by the judge
well actually it serves you know
no i think in my mind no punishment
because she is going to be able to walk
free 1800 days basically is four years
and so i don't think that this is
justice i cannot i cannot get over the
fact that this judge only found her
guilty of abandonment of a corpse and in
fact all of the other you know crimes
that she was charged with and her
husband and he dropped the charges
against the husband those crimes there
was plenty of evidence for those crimes
for murder in the first degree abuse of
a child murder in the second degree
tampering with evidence i don't think he
watched
i watch so i'm in shock and i don't
think it's enough time and i don't think
it was the right judgment yeah uh lisa
at a hearing on thursday all charges
against pete were dropped do you think
that was the right call
well here's the thing if there was not
enough evidence there to convince a
judge at a bench trial then the state
didn't do their job and that's what it
comes down to so they didn't have a jury
they didn't have to deal with the
emotions of that you would hope the
judge is completely unbiased because
that's what a judge is supposed to to be
um so
you know in the in the long run they
need to do better and learn a lesson
from this because we don't know
factually how she died she was killed if
it was suicide and there just wasn't
enough evidence to convince this judge
yeah the defense in this situation is
probably the smartest person in the room
because he decided bench trial over a
jury trial we don't know if it was gone
the same way as lisa kind of pointed out
if it was going the same way with the
jury so the defense made the right
choice it seems well we'll continue as
the case develops when we come back the
pike county massacre two witnesses opt
to be shown on video as the
prosecution's case continues against
george wagner iv
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
family member of the victims gives
emotional testimony in the pike county
massacre trial of george wagner iv in
ohio wagner along with his brother jake
and their parents are charged with
murdering eight members of the rodent
and gilly families in april of 2016.
prosecutors say the shooting deaths came
amid a custody dispute involving a young
child jake shared with hannah rhoden the
victims were found shot to death in
their homes in four different locations
most were shot as they slept jake
previously pled guilty to the murders
and will spend the rest of his life in
prison he has agreed to testify against
his brother and father george wagner
says he's not guilty because he didn't
actually pull the trigger
thursday morning kenneth rhoden's family
member took the stand kenneth was the
eighth victim killed donald stone
emotionally recounted finding his cousin
dead in his trailer before calling 9-1-1
so you walked into the residence
together and you said luke was there
first but then you and then what
happened then we walked in
he
we walked into the
supposedly the living room
and i noticed to the right i didn't see
him in there nowhere so i've
seen a stairway to the right
and i walked up the stairway
and that's where i found him up there in
his bed
and when you say you found him
rhoden's son luke who lived with his
mother at the time of the murders then
took the stand luke was with donald when
kenneth's body was discovered he
described an interaction he had with the
wagners before the killings happened
did you ever know
on the wagoner's
not a lot
what about billy wagner
yeah
one time i was out at his property with
my dad and chris learning the backhoe to
for him to do something and
he was
well the starters start tobacco up and
the
background wouldn't start so he got a
hole my dad and chris i was standing
there on the trailer and
uh he was standing beside me and he said
there's a
little time he said he see those two
people he said there's some really good
people he said but there had
if they ever had the what mess with him
if he had a tussle with him whatever
that he'd have to shoot him
did he explain why that was or did he
say anything more no
that was it
all right we finally have victims or
witnesses sorry to discuss not being the
family members of these victims so lisa
what did the prosecution get from luke
that pushed this case to a guilty beyond
reasonable doubt
i think
his authenticity when he was on the
stand completely congruent and truthful
especially when he revealed that his own
family had a marijuana grow business and
they made money from it there's a
defense theory that the cartel is
responsible for these murders because of
money owed and them wanting to take over
the business because he was so
forthcoming with the business and he
said that yes people owe them money but
not a lot of money um in this
particular drug business showed that
that wasn't the issue somebody wasn't
trying to take over this this small
business the most that they had produced
at one point was uh three pounds of
marijuana and not enough for a cartel to
take out an entire family
i would tend to agree based on what i l
know little of in the criminal law and
marijuana but terry did the defense hurt
the prosecution's case on
cross-examination at all
not at all not in my opinion i agree 100
with lisa listen the cross of donald
stone remember that's kenneth's first
cousin and they were very close they
mentioned that kenneth was well off and
it was an implication that he was making
lots of money from his marijuana
business but i don't think that that is
going to hit home with the jury they
understand this was a family dispute and
the cross of luke it was and lucas
kenneth's son remember luke was a little
more in terms of the prosecution going
after this marijuana business he asked a
lot of questions did you make money did
you help your father out and luke went
into it and i've got to hand it to him
it was cool calm and collected he talked
about that marijuana business like it
was you know selling bread not a big
deal they mentioned it on direct
examination i think to take the thunder
away from the cross and they did it
worked perfectly and essentially you
couldn't really say that people owed
kenneth money and he made it very clear
luke made it very clear that his dad
oftentimes lent people money his dad was
a good person people liked him and so i
think that jury is going to walk away
with the cross-examination
as not really making any points saying
things that really don't matter they
understand that this was a custody
battle that's why these murders occurred
all right let's see how this case
continues thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you